das kommando und herzlich willkommen bei
kochen lernen mitchell
hier lernen sie alles was in china und
dieses mehr wie simon
aber keine angst die jungen so viola
petersson zurechtgebogen bei uns im team
in plains der frage bist du blöd du bist
du noch leben würde konkret ansetzen
er soll mal spinnst jetzt um so die
zuschauer sahen damit bleibt jetzt sogar
sonst müssten es nicht im fernsehen
lernen wie man kartoffeln schält aus
machen wir doch mal den debald ist
fragen sie doch mal den zuschauer was
der unterschied ist zu steinen
kartoffeln probieren sie mal her
in was für einer hand halte ich das ei
und in was für einer
den cut off
das weiß der zuschauer nicht weil der
sind die so blöd wie ein von boni cloud
ist ist der vergleich noch gut nur so
kannst du ja wo es ist es sei und
bewusster kartoffel
aber ich glaube das ist ja vor dem was
für den adidas eingelegt habe vor dem 1
spinnst du komplett über sollten dieses
medium kommt jetzt hat einmal accra mit
nummer airplay behindert bist du und du
dich dazu da kochen diese die ganze
angelegenheit mit all ihren boss das
leben ist ihm ja wurscht wo es den jetzt
zum beispiel dass zuerst das ei da war
und der vorteile und dafür
davor erschienen aber dafür muss ein
gewisses unter die räder
moment ich mich verabschieden wir uns
und die sehen uns beim nächsten mal wird
es heißt was war zuerst da der kartoffel
oder garantiert ich habe ganz einfach
natürlich weiß der landwirt arbeitet der
muss zu den kartoffeln pflanzen muss
aber vorher der kartoffelkiste und not
davor gewarnt wird genau uns vom
landwirt gaddafi und der landwirt aber
an bord aber irgendwann musste die nord
wird click to get is wrong
die kinder wurden land blickt er den
katholischen die nahrung donna dass die
hydranten